maybe not that's why we want you to
negotiate the swap I'm an Insurance
lawyer are you good at what you do an
American attorney played by Tom Hanks is
asked to negotiate with the Soviet Union
during the Cold War to exchange captured
spies Hanks's character travels to
Berlin the Cold War era comes back to
life on the set of the thriller bridge
of spies bernard-henri she was the
movies set director he's been nominated
for two major awards for his work that's
why our cruising the godson make me it
was overwhelming what a night I learned
that I'm nominated for a bafta and an
Oscar Oh almost too much I don't know
how to react tell me my wife came and
hugged me I wanted to tell the whole
world I rang my neighbor's door bell and
hold him walk I don't know what was
happening that avocados the garlic were
missing we saw Henry she's responsible
for putting together a movies
furnishings and props he looks all over
Europe for the right items first he
conducts research on when and where the
film is set
but the final look is burn hot henricks
own creative interpretation and each
mock the Nocti earthshake conduct
research by considering what suits the
cliche we want to produce it doesn't all
have to be absolutely accurate all the
time not one-to-one the way it actually
was in the past that was you adapted a
bit consciously how Papa boost henrich
has been designing movie sets for 40
years some of the films were major
international productions like the spy
thriller the bourne conspiracy it's the
story of Jason Bourne a former CIA
assassin the title character was played
by Matt Damon
in Valkyrie starring Tom Cruise as
Hitler's would-be assassin Klaus von
Stauffenberg Baron HUD henrich designed
the locations in the style of the Nazi
era he researched for months to get the
atmosphere of the sets and props just
write another of Henry's third rush sets
is seen in the movie monuments men since
the 1990s the German film studio babbles
Berg has produced ever more elaborate
international blockbusters but here's
some love their tight what's developed
here over the course of time is enormous
I've worked in 23 countries always
traveling and I've worked on a great
many productions here in barbels bag
especially in the 1990s that gave me the
opportunity to finally work at home but
not nerdy Muisca chemo and itõs to our
button studio Babelsberg and parks damn
near berlin is Europe's largest film
studio it's been producing films since
nineteen twelve
it's noted for its high quality
craftsmanship it's art departments
cabinet makers metal workers and
painters produce film sets here Baron
had henrich commissions the elaborate
one-of-a-kind items he can't find
elsewhere captain england and i found a
huge collection of art deco furniture in
england and i thought this was the
fitting desk for these are unfortunately
it was on loan and not available but
it's off a fool but I had photos of and
so I turned to the art department at
stelio Baba's back for help that's our
depart department made the drawings &
stereo barbers bag made it in two or
three days and there it is the situation
the man Henry's has met many Hollywood
stars at film shoots in baubles Berg
like here in his most recent bridge of
spies capably done it can't look like
our justice system what's the evidence
look like pretty overwhelming great
great these are fleas and what is huge
television radio record player
everything it pleased Spielberg you know
I mean Tom Hanks Spielberg bought it and
gave it to Tom Hanks as a present
Thanksgiving the storeroom at babbles
Berg is like a second home for hen reesh
but the BAFTA Awards on februari 14th in
London and the Oscars two weeks later in
Los Angeles our new terrain
if Malika won't I'm not accustomed to
getting prizes my work and I'm not
camera shy I've met lots of famous
people so that doesn't bother me but to
go there now and be in the limelight
makes me feel a bit queasy omegas food I
see stop for the man behind the scenes
it will also be a reunion with old
acquaintances from bridge of spies and
decades in the film business